Bueno todavía el avión de sigue bastante
tranquilo como lo ven atrás las
editoriales están todavía finalizando la
instalación de sus estánda pero las
puertas de la Feria Internacional del
Libro de Bogotá ya están abiertas y
durante 15 días el público y Los
profesionales de la industria literaria
van a poder recorrer los 53 mil metros
cuadrados dedicados a la gran fiesta de
la literatura en Colombia del lado de
las novedades de Esta división número 35
podemos destacar que Cali la sucursal
del cielo y capital del departamento
colombiano del Valle del cauca es la
primera ciudad invitada de toda la
historia de la filboy y México es el
país invitado de honor por tercera vez
México que llegó con una delegación de
80 personalidades entre ellas
periodista Jorge volpi el escritor y
también Daniel
el influencer pero en total son 500
autores de 25 países diferentes que van
a poder conocer a sus lectores presentar
sus libros y participar a charlas y de
hecho el gran evento de este miércoles
19 de abril para el segundo día de la
filbo será sin duda el conversatorio con
la escritora nigeriana
de las artistas estrellas de esta
edición y hablará de esos temas
proyectos como lo son la familia La Raza
y las raíces